please welcome david alvarez mike bice
and josh andre rivera
[Applause]
i'm so honored that you would come here
thank you so much we're so proud to be
doing west side story week
what
was it like
making this film for you guys and i love
steven so much what was your experience
like with him mike
personally it was
it was an honor to witness him because
he came at it and approached the
material from such a place of respect
and love
and that
was an infectious kind of uh
place to to start this journey i think
for all of us and it spread like
wildfire through the cast
and um i don't know i mean he's just an
amazing
he's an amazing director we all know
this yeah but
he's an amazing person yes yeah really a
genuine authentic human and it's a very
rare thing
to come across and that was incredible
josh when you were doing this film how
did you handle our approach
taking on this character that was going
to be so fateful in the story well i
think
it was a nice process that helped me
grow a lot as an actor in person thanks
to the welcoming environment that
everybody cultivated on the creative
team and the cast
that at a certain point you know
i really really had to trust myself and
trust everybody else and
and
you know cooperate and collaborate to to
make
what just so excited for you to see it
ended up being like one of the most
special experiences in my entire life
and i think it's one of the most special
films ever made i really do it is hard i
thought a lot about this week and how i
would try to honor and bring to life
all the tones and nuances and yet big
sweeping
thought-provoking you know
life-affirming
things that are in this film because
this is as good as it gets in
storytelling um and and filmmaking and
you're dancing and you're fighting and
you're singing and you're acting and
it's everything
[Applause]
you were in the military i was yes um
how did this experience compared to the
diligence
of that when you get into something as
creative but demanding as this yeah you
know um i spent three years in the army
and
it honestly
it made me a
a better artist in some way and i think
i actually took a lot from that
experience into my character in bernardo
um bernardo is a fighter and he's got
that warrior inside of him and i you
know that i felt like i tapped into that
when i was in the army
but when you make a movie like this with
steven spielberg um and you feel that
passion and that love and that energy
and you're telling such a powerful
message um to a generation that needs to
hear it it's
that's when i'm
when i'm reminded this is why i do it
this is why i love it so much and this
is why i can't give up and this is what
i want to do for the rest of my life
this film just really has it all and in
getting to know you guys i was wondering
if i could ask you the final questions
that i've also asked to rachel and
ariana
as well will you do the uh final
questions with me real quick
[Applause]
um mike will you tell me the last lie
you told oh
[Laughter]
coming in hot oh wow what was that last
lie that i told
um i don't remember it i think they're
too frequent
yes um too many to remember you have too
many to remember
uh uh uh mike has never lie
i probably lied about uh what i ate
honestly because like really what i had
was like a chocolate croissant like
cookies you know what i mean i was like
yeah no i had asparagus
okay
a food life interesting i like it all
right josh one detail behind the scenes
a quick memory that we wouldn't know
about
i just bought this really cool underwear
that had a bunch of bacon and eggs on it
and that's what i was wearing underneath
my chino costume during dance at the gym
[Applause]
bacon and eggs well that part lays well
david what's your latest food craving i
guess hot cheetos nice um okay mike what
song should we put into heavy rotation
right now oh my gosh um
oh my gosh um
what's the one i'm thinking love will
tear us apart oh god but that's not
that's like joy division
not actually i was thinking
i i would go for it okay that love will
tear us apart by joy division a classic
josh
give me a favorite sunday movie uh
favorite sunday movie uh so i do this
thing with my friends where we get
together and uh we watch like terrible
80s action any
schwarzenegger movie that's like not
predator terminator
[Music]
yes okay david um
a favorite steven moment
i think it has to be um this moment we
were dancing at the gym we were doing
shooting the dance of the gym sequence
um
and it was like this beautiful shot that
he got and he was just so excited and he
got the whole ensemble he's like
everyone come over here and we get
behind we see the playback and just the
whole room roars out and just like it
was just an insane party and everyone
was hugging everyone i remember i just
looked over at stephen and i hugged him
i'm like this is incredible you know and
it was just a beautiful moment because i
think throughout this whole time of
shooting this we all knew we were
creating and making something so special
and we were just so grateful to be there
every single day and that you did thank
you so much
because it's a testament to you
josh andreas rivera mike tyson david
alvarez be sure to catch west side
stories in theaters
today
[Music]